how to load Sony film Sim Mach faster
this is a workaround method for fast
speeching between film recipes on Sony
cameras by using the memory recall mode
with memory recall mode you can save up
to seven film simulation sterious
turning camera and easily switch between
them in seconds so first step go into
the picture profile menu and load your
favorite film simulation settings you
can find a couple film simulation
recipes on my channel playlist I
personally added the film recipe for
portrait 800 for it buttery soft
contrast and beautiful candy light
colors at the temperature and the color
filter values for a recipe and now let's
go into memory recall mode to save it on
your cameras you'll find it in the
shooting mode camera settings and memory
hit okay to enter and save it to your
desired memory slot in older cameras
you'll find it at shoot mode and drive
save it and now on the top dial you
should find the memory recall mode
switch to it and voila now every time
you switch to memory recall one you'll
be ready to shoot your favorite film
simulations instantly shoot more edit
less with film simulations